سأقوم بالخصم من أنا دانيال بدلاً من ذلك
معًا فنحن مهندسون معماريون
ومصورون ، نهجنا هو اللعب
باحترام وهندسة داخل
مشهد حضري والآثار الجانبية التي
نسافر بها حول العالم لاستكشاف الجوانب غير المرئية
للمباني حتى نتمكن من سرد
القصص للصورة التي نراها  هي رحلة
للقاء مع المبدعين الآخرين المتشابهين في التفكير
والمبدعين الملهمين في الأجواء ، نحن
نستكشف عمليات الشراء قبل كل شيء في المركز بصفتنا
تعاونًا جديدًا يجمع بين
ورش عمل المعارض والاستوديوهات القائمة حيث
يتم إعطاء الفنانين الأساسيين الأدوات لبدء
الإبداع لمعرفة كيفية ذلك  أتيت لكي
نلتقي بمدير كل شارع كرة القدم
، أنا أصلاً من ليتوانيا ، درست
في الولايات المتحدة وكنت في فرنسا ،
ثم كانت المحطة الأخيرة كانت دبي كنت هناك
على قيد الحياة وتتألف من 91
مستودعًا مختلفًا كانت في السابق  مصنع رخام قديم
ينتمي إلى عائلة دائرة
كنت أرغب في تقديم مساهمة ذات مغزى
للفنون والثقافة بالنسبة لي ،
فإن Circle Avenue تدور حول جلب
مجتمع أقرب إلى الفنون والثقافة من
خلال مجموعة متنوعة من الأشكال والتجارب الفنية ،
هناك مجتمع فني محلي رائع
هنا
وأفراد موهوبون حقًا
يشاركون في إنشاء التاريخ
وإنتاج أعمال رائعة
أصبحت الآن معترف بها
دوليًا.  عبادة
من الخارج ونحن فضوليون بشأن
ما تفعله يا رفاق ، نحن هنا نقوم بتخصيص حذاء رياضي
كيف تشعر عندما
تعمل في هذا الفضاء مع كل هذا الفن من
حولك ، إنه أمر جيد حقًا إنه
مصدر إلهام لنا كفنانين لأنه بمجرد
وصولك  في دبي ، تشعر أن
كل شيء مصقول للغاية بمجرد
أن تتعرف على المشهد الإبداعي ،
ستدرك أنه يمكنك فعل ما
تريد ، تحتاج فقط إلى العثور على
المكان المناسب للقيام بذلك ،
وتوقف عن العمل ، فنحن نبني
البنية التحتية للفنون ليس فقط
لمدينة دبي ولكن بالنسبة
للإمارات والمنطقة في الماضي ، ننتج
حوالي 3000 حدث نحتي مفتوح
ومجاني للجمهور و  نتيجة لذلك ،
شهدنا ارتفاعًا في مجتمعنا ، كان من
دواعي سرورنا أن نلتقي بالفنانات المحلية
شيخة وتم تجاوز الغرفة الجماعية في
توسيع توسعة أعمالها لأول مرة ،
وأنا دائمًا ما أميل إلى قول هذا عندما
تشعر بالراحة أنك تميل إلى القيام
بأعمال مملة و  أحب أن أدفع نفسي
في هذا النوع من الزاوية غير المريحة
، من المهم جدًا
احتضان التاريخ والسياق والعناصر المحلية باستمرار
قبل أن نتمكن من إنشاء
قصة خاصة بنا يفخر بها هؤلاء الفنانون المحليون
من أين أتوا وأن
يروا بوضوح  حيث
سيتمكنون من مقابلة هذا الفنان الملهم
شعروا أننا نكتشف
بداية شيء خاص في
المشهد الفني للجهاز